Well,
science is telling us that we can do
phenomenal things if we put our minds
and our resources to us.
I mean,
I think science is probably the best
example of you put resources into
something and you let the creativity and
the brilliance of the minds throughout
the world and certainly not only in this
country,
throughout the world,
and phenomenally good things can happen.
You've got to make sure that there's
checks and balances on that because
science can also lead to things that are
not so good.
You know?
And that is a whole ethical issues of
manipulating at the genomics,
at the genomic level,
the whole issues of,
of embryos and creating people to your
own fashionable boutique,
liking all those things.
You've got to really be very,
very careful that,
but science at its most pure where
you're sweet,
you're looking for discovery and you're
going to use discovery for the
betterment of mankind.
I think science stands out among more
some of the most important,
uh,
endeavors that the humankind can pursue.
Mankind evolves.
I mean,
there's no doubt that we have evolved
the whole issue of evolving through
various lower species.
To our own species of the human.
But there's also the continuing
evolution,
uh,
that is associated with mankind.
And a lot of that is using what
specifically and particularly and
peculiarly makes you a human being.
And that is your intellect and your
will.
You have a choice.
You can analyze things and you can act
in an intellectual manner.
And that is to me that the very
foundation of what science is,
how you can better your own lot,
the lot of the other citizens of the
world while you're paying attention to
and preserving the world you live in,
which is the reason why things like the
environment are so,
so important.
When we try and analyze all we doing
things that are detrimental to the
environment.
And if so,
how do we stop it?
And if we have to stop it,
how do we replace it with something
that's environmentally friendly?
And I think science is going to lead us
there.
And it's the goodwill that you have to
try and preserve your own species as
well as preserve the environment,
I.
E.
Our planet.
Uh,
so that we can have thousands of more
years of,
of,
of people doing good things and leading
good lives.